this is my first question because I I
know that you're you were raised by
seeing him on there's a teachers public
school fifth sixth grade she's retired
now the last couple of years but so she
wants two grandkids more but yes she she
taught public school yeah mine did too
and did when you went to public school
nobody ever did that for me like Shannon
did like her teacher did you ever have
anything like that kind of a no no not
really I mean I knew because that was my
mother's reason for why couldn't I can
we get the you know the Star Trek toys
and no we can't afford it as long as we
can't afford it so poor because but but
she you know she definitely well she did
have one lesson that she kind of tried
to impart to me growing up well I really
wanted a dog when I was a kid in the new
house in Boston you know and there's a
barking you know pretty normal a bear
park whatever and my mom said you're not
responsible enough to have a dog I was
ten I was like I am responsible enough
she said you're right won't you show me
that you can do this you you have to
walk the dog every day twice a day I
said well okay let's get the dog she
goes no first you have to walk an
imaginary dog I was like it's right as
the Wooden's like twice a day around the
block as if you had the dog so I know
that you will do it and you're
responsible enough to do it so this
woman who I hope is watching gave me a
leash and I had to walk around the block
and worse we get to three weeks in and
she's like no I forget it I'm not giving
you she taught me the lesson of
disappointment like I didn't think you
follow through well I'd event yeah I
didn't get a dog and I thought I was so
deprived I did like the dumbest thing
you can do which you can that's the kind
of thing you tend to do when you're 18
which is how old I was and as soon as I
moved to LA inside to be an actor and
had no money and no job and lived in a
tiny apartment like on Cherokee and
yucca over there in Hollywood like I was
come yet
yeah and got a dog not only get a dog
but I got a husky which is like the most
you know if anyone has ever roam they
only want to escape yeah I mean that's
dared like missional I quickly realize
like oh you have to get the dog food
[Laughter]
broke on this dog has sad ending to the
story though which was that I used to
leave the dog in a little a little space
shared space in the apartment when I
went out to have some outdoor time and
now got stolen before the little
microchips and the stuff you can put in
it you know to track him down yeah yes
so somebody stole a dog but it's telling
that I didn't rush out and get another
dog probably he probably was not living
his best life with me very happy life on
a farm I did that I did the same thing
though when I was young I was like I I
think you when you're out here because I
moved out here to and you want
companionship or some kind of you can't
be lonely so I did that too it was a
dumb move
yeah when you have the least money the
smallest let's go 15 seconds left we're
gonna go on it keeps us time for a
rebound or a tip Brandon 20 is gonna
pick you up full court all right freeze
you gonna come up instead of ball screen
for Brandon Brandon you roll around to
the right Garcia come up set her back
screen for Kenny Kenny come out to the
wing for the three now when we got three
options
Brandon attacking right we'll look for
fries coming off the screen either
there go to County field three in the
corner you got this okay
no don't just not I'm gonna hear your
voice yes or no yes coach
[Applause]
so we'll talk about the film in a bit
but I did want to ask you is it true
that you speak Spanish like fluently I
would say possibly passively I love to
even get to that point I feel like I
can't I always try but there's it's like
unless you're like immersed around it
like constantly I feel like I'm just
it's not gonna happen that's the best
way to learn for sure I mean I did this
like the little kids TV series when I
was young and when I was 13 that season
that year was in Mexico yeah so I was in
Mexico for a year and and that's how I
that's how I picked it up so I learned
how to like when you were little do like
the older brain doesn't hold on we were
both very young so your kids speak
Spanish because they teach all the
languages now in schools I feel like my
daughter is 14 yeah and she's always
been a very good student and she's been
interested in Spanish and so I often
help her and now she's all of a sudden
she's got into the grade where she's
like in the harder Spanish classes and
she's getting better and I and she's
like at the point where I think she
might be passing me and I was like nope
this is not happening I don't mind that
I can't do your math homework over 14
years old but you will not know you are
not gonna be better Spanish to me and so
I've decided now I gotta likes take
classes I got a do study get a tutor to
keep up because I can't have my fourth
year she's like that sounds ridiculous
you're not using the impreza the
imperfect tense I know two tenses
Friesen now before the future that and
also the problem of Spanish is that you
learn a bunch of are it's like I learn
all these words yeah in Mexico some good
some you know yeah and then you go
somewhere else like you go to Spain or
you go South America and they're like no
that's not Spanish I'm like we talked
about it's not Spanish well like I've
never heard that word before in my life
Mexico in Mexico they don't speak no
Spanish and then they'll all like you
have a Mexican accent you an accent but
like I mean sort of like the southern
accent and the you know here
little bit more like Australia England
in here where like you know the UN
Australia I don't know just cuz you're
exposed to it as an actor to young age
you know I did a lot of yeah I like to
mimic like voices and stuff when I was a
kid I got a big kick out of that place
did like copy my friends voices and
stuff and my father when he lived with
us it was a big Richard Pryor fan oh
yeah yeah who was maybe one you know the
greatest stand-up comedian ever but not
PG and I can remember like a no records
of play I was in second grade third
grade fourth grade and I would imitate
him and do the jokes and he thought it
was the funniest thing in the world and
then one day we did like bring dad to
work day and he came in to talk about
being an auto mechanic and I thought it
was like oh now's a good time to launch
into the Richard Pryor thing that makes
my dad that's when the parents always
like they'd never done this before I
don't know where I don't know what's
happening okay well tell us about the
way back so it's about the new movie we
find this guy very much like down on his
luck he's drinking a case of beer a day
he's he's living in a cottage in G part
man he's you know he's got a job he
works construction but he's separated
from his wife and you can tell he's not
happy and he's not engaged in life yeah
and throughout the course the movie you
start to find out kind of what happened
that got into that place and also he
gets offered the job to coach the high
school basketball team that he used to
play for he was like a big high school
star doesn't want to do it he's afraid
he's nervous but finally he takes the
job you know it's one of those things
where he thinks he's gonna kind of come
in and really coach them and teach them
and it probably he gets more out of it
than the kids do you know incredible and
it doesn't pull any punches in terms of
life is hard you're gonna have problems
you're gonna suffer it's gonna be
difficult sometimes really really hard
but still says like link you get better
you're gonna you can conquer your
problem you can climb over these walls
you know you can improve your life and
and be hopeful inspiring and that's what
I really loved about it yeah and the
joyful experience for me I really loved
doing it I love those guys it kind of
rekindled my love for acting and you
know and I'm really proud of the proud
of
yeah it's one of those movies like it
means something like the messages so
it's not just like a movie laughs at all
and those are all great too but I liked
it I had a really solid message
I like that like and I always say this
we have a lot of different stories on
this show
everybody's addicted to something like
it might not be so obvious that it's
alcohol for you or drugs or whatever but
everybody has that and I love the
redemption factor of the film and I feel
like it's very relatable and is there a
reason why you wanted to sign up to do
this one yeah well I mean for all those
reasons I agree with you that compulsive
behavior you know we have this brain
that sort of works like a reward center
right like our brain tells us like we
eat food and it sends a little bit of
reward dopamine or serotonin without the
fact that like it's not yes you can look
at things kind of isolated silos ago
well that's an opioid
I think problem that's an alcohol
problem that's a compulsive shopping
problem that's anorexia that's
overeating that's gambling that's porn
and alcohol beside you see that
basically it's a lot of different
behaviors but what they're all trying to
do is like get at some feeling of
discomfort yeah they're trying to solve
that by doing something that is clearly
not good for them not healthy you know
it mentally you know the front brain but
that like other part keeps asking for
that reward and that good feeling and
then you create so kind of two minds
like I know I don't want to do this and
yet I kind of can't stop and that's when
it goes from me you know something
healthy and celebratory like alcohol
should be great have a drink celebrate
if you can do that to something that's
like you know this is clearly not
helping my life yeah yeah I'm still
doing it so so why is that and then I
think the movie takes a good look at
that in a way that's not you know it's
not a sermon it's not a lecture that's
like the church and school and I used to
be inspired he had to find out that like
what was really important about me for
that being a recovering alcoholic myself
is that you're not defined by your
problems yes not who you are yeah
whatever it is the issues you're not the
bankrupt person you're not the overeater
you're not the opioid you're like a
whole big complicated person and that's
one part of it and also we tend to see
those problems when they arrive in our
lives and kind of sit in and go now I'm
stuck you're not stuck yeah you can move
past that stuff you can change your life
you can make it yeah
[Applause]
it's just a really really great message
be sure to catch the way back in
theaters tomorrow I can't recommend it
enough subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going